[Musique]
le festival de cannes théâtre des rêves
par la présence de nombreuses stars sur
le tapis rouge certains élèves de 3e
aussi l'institut de l'image et du son à
del en cours ont pu goûter à ce songe
qu'ils aient remporté un concours ou
qu'ils aient travaillé sur place pour
l'évènement participer à la grande fête
du cinéma du cinéma est une chance pour
ces étudiants en audiovisuel le
reportage avec ces images d'alexis
garneau en collaboration avec radio
sensations d'elancourt à cannes il n'y a
qu'un pas romane et les halons franchi
en remportant le concours europcar parmi
dix projets sélectionnés récompense pour
les deux réalisatrices en herbe de 3 i/s
un ticket pour le festival du cinéma et
surtout une montée des célèbres marches
comme les grands du métier un rêve pour
ces deux étudiants en audiovisuel les
spéciales de cannes pour moi ça
représente bas le rêve du cinéma qui est
concrétisé une fois qu'on a travaillé
très dur et qu'on présente un film ou
conviennent en voir c'est vraiment
l'aboutissement d'un rêve et construit
par le parrain réalisateurs comme par
les autres qui va le voir principe du
concours non plus réalisé un court
métrage comme les années précédentes
mais proposer un spot publicitaire d'une
minute faisant la promotion du groupe de
location de véhicules basée à voisins le
bretonneux les ironman se sont
distingués avec escapade littoral une
vidéo qui invite au voyage
c'est un voyage quand même initiatique
pour une personne qui qui part en voyage
et se découvre elle même tout au long de
ce voyage là et du coup c'est un spot
digital d'une minute dans lequel on
donne aussi envie aux spectateurs de
voyager et de peut-être se découvrir
aussi un air d'autres étudiants de
l'institut de l'image et du son 6 plus
exactement sont à cannes depuis le début
du festival pour travailler guillaume
ulysse agathe camille alexandre et
gwenaëlle sont en stage au département
audiovisuel du festival et grâce à un
partenariat avec leur école ils ont dans
ce cadre plusieurs missions ça peut
aller de
filmer la montée des marches de certains
films le soir ou bien de couvrir des
master class des rendez vous avec des
personnalités connues du cinéma le toute
la journée on a également des
présentations de films classiques dans
le cadre de cannes classics et
quelquefois également allés filmer le
les événements qui assurent le cinéma de
la plage de découvrir vraiment le
festival le palais de l'intérieur c'est
assez impressionnant ce que nous on le
voit que de l'extérieur à la télé las
d'être vraiment au coeur du festival
c'est c'est vraiment très sympa une
expérience et des souvenirs plein la
tête qu'ils ramèneront dans leurs
bagages et on retrouve une dernière fois
depuis cannes hugo casadamont de la
rédaction de radio sensations 2
yvelinois qui sont à la fiche du
deuxième film de nicolas bedos
présentait en hors compétition
l'un est né et a vécu à versailles
l'autre est né et a vécu à montfort
l'amaury denis podalydès et guillaume
canet se retrouve cette année à cannes
pour le nouveau film de nicolas bedos la
belle époque
alors ce film est présenté hors
compétition c'est l'histoire d'un homme
daniel auteuil qui veut revivre la plus
belle semaine de sa vie celle où il a
trouvé l'amour je vous propose tout de
suite d'écoutés
guillaume canet et nicolas bedos et de
regarder les premières images du film on
est un peu comme des gosses un copain on
a un scénario dans les mains on est là
on est en dessous dans un dans un
bistrot et on a fait une liste
on a fait une liste et est en haut de la
liste il y avait
il y avait daniel auteuil avec guillaume
canet non moi je vais vous dire quand on
a commencé le film j'étais très inquiet
parce que parce que j'avais sur
rock'n'roll les mêmes maquilleur en fait
je suis rade ahlmann et je dis comment
ça se passe au film nicolas et je voyais
des fois ça va c'est parfois un peu
tendu mais ça et me connaissant je vais
très très vite dans le rouge
et sachant que nicolas aussi j'avais
très peur quand il m'a proposé le film
que ça se passe pas bien du tout comme
je lui ai dit je te dis il vaut mieux
qu'on reste amis et parce que voilà il
me dit mais non non t'inquiète pas du
cher monsieur dream votre fils et moi
serions très honoré de vous offrir la
soirée de votre choix
dans le cadre des voyageurs du temple
moi c'est des histoires d'amour qui
m'ont beaucoup touché aussi dans le
scénario et qui m'ont beaucoup plu est
ce que ce que ça racontait parce que
c'est des deux histoires d'amour
l'une passionnés l'autre qui s'éteint
mais qui va se raviver justement grâce
aussi à au feu de la première
mademoiselle
parce qu'il vous attend je sais pas ce
qu'il va se passer
le à fond et ce qui m'a touché la danse
est aussi le rapport de 2 de mon
personnage avec le personnage cliente
après daniel qui est un mentor un père
spirituel et qui cet homme lui a apporté
du bonheur à un moment où il y en avait
pas et parce qu'il s'était un couple
c'était une image du bonheur en fait et
est ce que je trouve très très beau
c'est finalement le personnage que
j'interprète se retrouve un moment dans
une mission de faire que cet homme
retrouve le bonheur
enfin pour cette ultime focus de la
semaine sur un film financé par la
région ile-de-france petit voyage en
amérique du sud la cordillère des songes
du chilien patricio guzmán est projeté
dans la sélection officielle de cannes
en séance spéciale
un film consacré la cordillère des andes
cet immense chaîne de montagnes qui
parcourt le continent du nord reçu des
enclaves le chili dans la cordillère des
songes patricio guzmán dépeint notamment
les ravages du capitalisme sur place et
depuis le départ de pinochet
si vous qu'à manche était locale et non
mapa cassez n'en vienne et saigne à
l'islam
d'un beau co existent en cabine publique
parvenir à résister à l'eau
n'aviez vous bénira qui s'il a
l'autorisation
etait-ce une immense au talent et à
l'utile et non chinoises qu'il est nous
finalement robin saison et le 100% del
territorio est propice à rihanna
[Musique]